dissonance 3 is set to air in the summer
of 2019 and fans are getting super
impatient so to tie you guys over the
Disney Channel has released our favorite
characters new official looks and we're
not joking when we say they're to die
for we've got a surprise for you at the
end of this video so stay tuned Carlos
the cast of descendants 3 is added again
and this time they've seriously upped
their fashion game although we didn't
think it was possible fashion designer
Kara Sun brings her talents to a brand
new level and we can't wait to show you
all of her latest designs the Disney
Channel just released d3 new promo
images and fans are freaking out let's
start off with Carlos Deville who is
arguably one of the most likable
villains ever
Carlos is usually seen sporting reds
blacks and whites which is probably the
only thing he and his mother have in
common in the first film
Carlos leather jacket is lined with fur
and his hair seems to be more white than
gray but come descendants - he was given
a mega makeover Carlos traded in the fur
lining for a short-sleeved jacket on top
of that his hair was dyed gray and his
outfit given silver highlights the
change was pretty drastic but it's
nothing compared to his newest look
Carlos is now wearing a full leather
bodysuit and he seems to have put the
color red on the back burner Carlos his
hair is longer than ever giving him an
aged and refined look is it just us or
does Carlos look like he's about to walk
on the moon this villain looks is better
than ever
don't you just love his outfit was a
mistake to underestimate being a
daughter of the Evil Queen is no joke
especially when she wants to be the
fairest of them all
but Evie never let her mother's
obsessions stop her from looking her
best the blueberry princess is known for
her wicked fashion sense and confident
nature so we're not surprised that her
latest look and body's her character in
the first film he is rocking a blue
leather poncho tights and a graffiti
t-shirt and a graffiti skirt she looks
like a total Punk and we love it become
descendants to Evie's look was
remastered
a classy way she ditched the long
sleeves and opted for an adorable blue
dress but now Evie's got a brand new
outfit and we're totally freaking out
over it doesn't she look amazing
the villains hair is the longest it's
ever been and it's a lot less wavy than
usual much like Carlos Phoebe is wearing
a full bodysuit
however hers is accompanied by a skirt
fans are used to seeing Evy wearing blue
outfits with hints of red and black but
it looks like her colors have been
switched around what we're most
impressed by though is her gorgeous
tiara if you think Evie looks amazing
just wait until you see mal luma might
be mouths biggest enemy but that's never
stopped us from loving her she's feisty
talented and 100% wicked so what's not
to love when we were first introduced to
Emma in descendants - she looks like a
typical pirate but now her look is much
more sophisticated uma is usually seen
wearing a pirate hat brown boots and a
leather jacket and a skirt but her new
style is so much better than we could
have ever imagined
just take a look at her outfit she looks
like a total rebel her light blue hair
has been dyed a more vibrant shade and
she's gotten rid of the majority of her
braids umas leather jacket is jewel
encrusted and she's traded in her skirt
for some matching pants we absolutely
love her transformation but the best
part is Lumas crown which seems to be
fashioned with her hair alone Jay before
transferring to auradon prep Jay was
known for being a professional thief he
could pretty much do anything he wanted
without getting caught but now he only
uses the five finger discount when he
has no other choice in the first film
Jay typically wears his red beanie a
sleeveless leather jacket and blue pants
become D to Jay's outfit is made to be
more vibrant and peppy than ever his red
beanie has turned black and his pants
have more red in them Jay's makeover is
beyond impressive but it pales in
comparison to his d3 outfit Jay looks
super grown-up in his yellow and red
leather suit he's wearing big combat
boots and his arms are completely
covered for one
did you guys notice that J no longer is
wearing his famous beanie because we
sure did this hothead looks like a brand
new person and we're loving it I'm back
now now might be a nice person but she's
a villain nonetheless and she's not
about to go changing that for anyone
sorry Ben mal is usually clad in her
mother's colors so we can expect her to
be wearing purples pinks and greens in
the first film Mouse outfit is
predominantly purple and so is her hair
but come descendants to Mouse looks
start to change in D to Mouse hair is
more pink than purple and she has a
fresh pair of bangs on top of that her
jacket is decorated with jewels chains
and green highlights she's reaping
Maleficent's look and ward diggin ed
however her d3 makeover is by far the
most breathtaking of all now as hair is
so purple it comes off as blue and her
outfit makes her look like a superstar
she's wearing green combat boots a
cropped leather jacket and dark pants
now looks just about ready to win a
battle and we're hoping that she will
Hades we promised you a surprise and
here it is
Hades official look it's been almost a
year since actor Shia and Jackson was
confirmed to play Hades in the last
descendants film and we've been
patiently awaiting his grand debut the
Disney Channel has officially released
Hades highly anticipated look and we're
in love she looks like a total rebel
so if Hades does turn out to be mouths
dad we now understand why Maleficent
fell for the bad boy in the first place
Hades has always been characterized by
his vibrant blue hair and long black
robe but we're not surprised that
designers chose to give him an edgier
style Hades hair is bright blue and
fashioned into a mohawk he's got a
classic leather jacket on and he studded
to perfection
Hades looks mean and ruthless but then
again we'd expect nothing less from the
god of the underworld
so which 2d three makeover is your
favorite let us know in the comments
below
and that's a wrap if you enjoyed this
video make sure to give it a big thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe to the
things for more descendants news to come
your way thanks for watching and see
next time
[Music]